[Music]
jeff we did a whole explainer on the
north star i hope you enjoyed that that
was great
no that's not just because we pay you so
no absolutely that it was a really good
one i uh you know
first of all you're not who knew that
you're uh that the north star was such a
poser that yeah it's very much a poser
yeah actually it's not it's fault it's
people want it to be so special and it
just isn't
so i wanna i have more
to tell you about how unspecial it is oh
awesome
we're at 40 ninth we're 49.
yes for those who missed it the north
star is the 49th brightest star in the
night sky right and
in the night sky it's not saying here i
am is not doing that all right so but
wait there's more
earth spinning on its axis and it's at
its north pole points upwards
close-ish to where the north star is on
the sky
all right
what i didn't tell you is i i don't know
no one has them anymore you have a play
with tops as a kid i did that's how old
i am you play at the top and it spins
and then eventually begins to wobble
right
okay
all right okay we have an official term
for that it's called precession
pre-session
that's an official term
so earth
wobbles
okay
do we spin once
and how often how long does it take to
spin once 24 hours i guess thank you
yeah
if you want to be precise it's actually
23 hours and 56 minutes and four seconds
wow
in case but that's another explainer
well you know why do we think it's 24
hours when it's actually that okay i
will that's a whole other
we'll we'll save that okay
okay all right so
uh we spend once in 24 hours and we
wobble
and the wobble takes 26 000 years
the wobble takes 26 000 years
correct
so we've only really completed one
wobble since caveman days right wow
you know 30 000 years ago right so
that's slow
and
it took some very careful measurements
and brilliant thinkers
throughout the last
thousand years two thousand years to
figure this out that this is actually
happening in the actual sky all right
so now
because we're wobbling it means the
north pole of earth
isn't always pointing towards the north
star
and we called it polaris
but wait a minute if it's no longer if
later on it's not going to point to
polaris not only is it not the north
star should we keep calling it polaris
or just sort of grandfather in well
that's what i once was back in the day
exactly
so if you look at that circle
the diameter of that circle is in
degrees is 23 and a half degrees
okay
okay
because that's how tipped we are from
vertical all right
okay that's earth that's what gives us
our seasons the fact that we're tipped
so we tip that and then we process
around
that central point all right
so if you draw that circle
on the
yes it will go through the north star
because that's what it is now but
any other stars that it comes near
one of the stars in the night sky i
think you've heard of it's called vega
okay vega is one of the brightest stars
of the night sky
it's about 30 light years away okay we
think there's a a a planetary system
forming around it we see a disc of
material
that's not quite discrete planets but
it's kind of it's it's working its way
towards
forming planets so we know some stuff
about vega in 14 000 years
the wobble will take the north pole axis
close enough to vega for that to be our
pole star
gotcha
and
in ancient egypt that was long enough
ago
you know four thousand five thousand
years ago that's an appreciable fraction
of the 26 000 years they had a different
pole star
than the north star
right so in recorded history
civilizations have had different pulsars
and only right now is it what we're
calling polaris wow
okay there's nothing magical or
permanent about it
wow it's like being in menudo
does anyone under 50 even know what that
references they have no idea what i'm
talking about right now
but for those of you who don't know
menudo was a boy band and they just kept
swapping out members one of which was
ricky martin
oh that forgot about that that's right
yeah so minuto was not a set of names
right it was a concept it was a concept
yes yes and it was always locked out the
members as they and they would age out
they'd be like 18. they'd be they age
out that's what it was yeah sorry manuel
your time is up
you got to go bro
you are now a man you must join the man
band you can stand on the board can't be
the boy band anymore
yeah so that's pretty wild yeah so the
north star is a concept and we sometimes
you won't have one when it's sort of
between other two stars we're not going
to have a north star that's dope i got i
love it
that is the most interesting thing about
the north star is that the north star
one is not the north star and two it
ain't even it's not even gonna be there
it's not gonna be there in a few
thousand years
and it's not even in the top forty and
it's not even stop 40.
you know that's yup that's pretty wild
all right that is totally wild now north
star one other thing it's the con man of
all stars
don't blame no don't blame the star
itself it's
okay you frog one more thing the north
star is a fraud go ahead
i got one more thing ready all right all
right
one of the consequences
of the precession
right is that the sun
is in a different part of the sky
at the same time of the year
in other words right now pick a month
okay right
it's up let's pick october okay and so
october astrologically
the sun is moving through libra okay
okay
well the precession of
the earth that the wobble
over the 26 000 years will
systematically put the sun in a
different constellation in the month of
october right
okay
so the entire zodiac
rotates through the calendar
wow
in fact
when the zodiac was codified
two and a half thousand years ago
wait a minute
that's like
one twelfth
of twenty six thousand
oh my gosh
so is october
still the month
for libra
no the sun was in libra
2000 years ago in october
all of that has shifted
and so
if you thought you were libra you're
actually scorpio right now and that's
when the sun gets all sexy
i didn't know you were fluent in this
so
the the zodiac people the astrologers
still
describe the sun being in these various
constellations as they were mapped out
2 200 years ago right between 2000 and
2400 years ago
and so if you're it's cancer scorpio
gemini
you would expect the sun to be in that
constellation the day you were born it
was
2200 years ago oh man that is so
it is not today it's all shifted
and they don't really they're not really
forthcoming about it no because if they
were then all of astrology would be oh
crap
that is oh man oh and not only that not
only that the the the
the the zodiac the the sun in the zodiac
actually passes through
a 13th constellation it's called
ophiuchus
all right god bless you
ophiuchus
wow okay in fact
the sun spends more time in ophiucus
than it does in scorpius okay
so
if you thought you were scorpio you were
probably ophiuchan and all scorpios and
all [ __ ] are currently libras
wow i just thought i'd put that out
there i i
i just want to know where where does
that leave cancer because that's what i
am okay are your cancer yeah i'm a
cancer so so cancer is one of the lamest
constellations ever constructed in the
night sky damn that there's like five
stars and they have like a crab with
claws and it's a crustacean it's like
what were you smoking what what opium
was working in your system to say oh
let's call that a crab man you just i
can't believe this it's like one i got a
lousy constellation two they made plus
those stars aren't very bright and
they're not okay
i got a lot if you ask if you ask
astrologers say there are 12 prominent
constellations in the sky no they're not
dead
there's like three that kind of look
like what they're supposed to
i got a lousy dim constellation they
made me into a stupid bottom feeder crab
and on top of that i'm a festering
malignancy so
yes which they named after krabs right
yes oh god yes
oh man cancer is it too late to be a
sagittarius where's where's cancer now
i gotta i don't know i don't keep it i
have to memorize that i'll come back to
you on another episode okay all right we
got to call it quits there just to round
out everything you didn't need to know
about the north star
and its brethren
very cool
star talk explainers neil degrasse tyson
keep looking up
[Music]